je n'ai droit à rien je n'ai plus aucun
droit je ne touche plus rien d'un pôle
emploi on a clairement dit il ya
quelques temps que je peux enfin je
rentrais pas dans le profil des
entreprises parce que voilà j'étais trop
pagé quoi on sort jamais en votre
mosquée rien et en fin de compte à la
fin du mois on s'en sort pas et c'est ça
qu'on a du mal à comprendre mon
sentiment il est de la lnr en colère la
france compte aujourd'hui 2 millions et
2002 chômeurs de longue durée soit 43 %
des demandeurs d'emploi toutes
catégories confondues
un chiffre qui explose selon l'insee ce
sont les personnes qui n'ont pas
travaillé depuis plus d'un an les chefs
d'entreprise sont réticents à l'idée de
les embaucher
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est des
personnes qui sont toujours mis à
l'écart et moi je me rends combien
contre ces personnes là sa peine de
trois ans qui sont au chômage il faut
bien avoir conscience une chose c'est
qu'ils sont jamais prioritaire
aujourd'hui ne le système français très
bien fait malgré tout mais il n'y est
plus il est plus adéquat pour ces gens
qui sont au chômage depuis depuis deux
trois ou quatre ans voire plus en 40 ans
les gouvernements successifs ont échoué
à inverser la courbe du chômage
l'association atd quart monde est à
l'initiative d'une loi pour résorber le
chômage de longue durée
elle est portée à la haute assemblée par
la sénatrice anne emery dumas face à ce
fléau
il serait illusoire de croire à
l'existence d'une seule et unique
solution miracle le principe est simple
expérimenté pour cinq ans l'embauchent
de chômeurs de longue durée en cdi en
créant des activités locales recruté par
des entreprises du secteur de l'économie
sociale et solidaire
ils troquent leur allocation contre 1
smic ainsi les chemins renoueront avec
le marché du travail l'emploi y en a pas
mais le travail en a
utopique comme projet nous allons vous
montrer les prémices de ce dispositif
expérimental il pourrait bien changer la
vie de milliers de personnes
comment inverser la courbe du chômage
est il possible de redonner du travail à
des chômeurs de longue durée
face à ce combat qui semble perdue
d'avancé
le gouvernement veut croire que tout est
possible que cette réalité du chômage le
dis je le redis nous n'avons pas tout
essayé
c'est l'objet même du texte contre le
chômage de longue durée que nous
discutons aujourd'hui janvier 2016
examiné en catimini et à une heure
tardive cette proposition de loi
pourrait bien révolutionner le quotidien
de milliers de personnes privées
d'emploi
l'objectif est clair résorber le chômage
de longue durée dans dix territoires
expérimentaux un emery dumas est
sénatrice de la nièvre
elle est aussi la rapporteur de la loi
au sénat dans ce combat pour l'emploi
il ne faut écarter par principe aucun
dispositif innovant car en la matière
l'imagination ne doit pas être et
les expériences mérite d'être tenté mais
certains sénateurs sont sceptiques
qui peut croire que c'est avec une telle
loi que disparaîtra le chômage de longue
durée
faire une loi pour faire une
expérimentation ça choque personne
encore une loi
il faut une loi pour pouvoir
expérimenter ce dispositif carte au
financement implique la réorientation de
certaines dépenses publiques
le projet s'appuie sur le droit à
l'expérimentation des collectivités
territoriales un droit inscrit dans la
constitution depuis 2003 ma conviction
c'est qu'on ne pourra jamais développer
l'emploi si on ne fait pas marché et
l'économie marchande économie de
référence économie maîtresse et l'autre
jambe de cette économie qui est
l'économie sociale et solidaire tout ça
c'est pas la panacée c'est pas avec ça
qu'on va régler le chômage mais pour moi
c'est un petit plus pour certains
territoires et il faut absolument rien
négliger cette proposition de loi est
adopté je vous remercie
selon l'association atd quart monde
un chômeur de longue durée coup de 15000
euros par an à l'état soit 33 milliards
d'euros pour l'ensemble de cette
catégorie
un coût qui prend en compte les dépenses
liées au chômage
les aides sociales les coûts indirects
et le moc a gagné en impôts et
cotisations sociales en réaffectant
toutes ces aides dans des salaires payés
au smic
la loi permet de redonner un travail on
cdi aux chômeurs volontaire à l'heure
actuelle cinq territoires sont déjà
candidats prémery dans la nièvre pipriac
en ille-et-vilaine grand mauléon dans
les deux sèvres colombey-les-belles en
meurthe-et-moselle
hejduk dans les bouches du rhône au
total ce seront 10 territoires pilotes
2000 chômeurs de longue durée pourrait
participer à cette expérimentation
prémery dans la nièvre 2000 habitants
autrefois une petite ville dynamique
fleuron de l'industrie du charbon de
bois
aujourd'hui elle subit de plein fouet la
crise l'usiné a fermé en 2002 laissant
sur le carreau 300 emplois à la grande
époque
elle employait jusqu'à 700 personnes la
sénatrice anne emery dumas nous emmène
visiter les locaux de la future
entreprise à but d'emplois on a eu la
fermeture de toutes ces entreprises
industrielles d'une certaine dimension
qui étaient implantés en milieu rural
comme c'était le cas à une plus grande
échelle en lorraine ou houdan ou dans le
nord
il faut donc repenser maintenant
l'avenir du territoire sur d'autres sur
d'autres basés à partir d'autres besoins
et d'autres possibilités d'emploi et ça
c'est tout une révolution culturelle à
effectuer aussi qui prend quand même un
peu de un peu de temps et le temps
presse
280 chômeurs de longue durée vivent sur
ce territoire
alors c'est pas dans cette partie là
c'est dans la partie à côté un des
premiers chantiers faire participer les
chômeurs à la rénovation de l'entreprise
dont on voit qu'il ya tout à faire la
fête voilà pour créer une entreprise à
l'intérieur de la voiture du bâtiment
vaut mieux payer les gens au travail que
de les payer au chômage quoi pour faire
pour faire court et l'expérimentation ça
consiste à faire la démonstration que
c'est possible de payer les gens au
travail plutôt qu'au chômage
sur le terrain c'est l'association atd
quart monde qui pilote le dispositif ici
à prémery marie laure brunet met sur
pied le projet zéro chômeur de longue
durée
ça fait presque peur mais en même temps
c'est un vrai challenge de dire que
voilà dans quelques mois dans neuf mois
dix mois anaïs il y aura plein de gens
qui viendront bosser le matin et qui
repartiront le soir chez eux en ayant
bossé leur 7h ou 8h fargeau
oh
son objectif désormais recensés les
compétences des demandeurs d'emploi
volontaire ce matin elle reçoit des
chômeurs de longue durée
la démarche est innovante il s'agit de
partir des qualifications et des envies
des chômeurs afin de créer des emplois
la loi a été votée ce que je vous
propose c'est réfléchissent ensemble
alors vous me disais ce que vous avez
fait épique et après on essaye de voir
qu est-ce que finalement vous pour y
faire aussi
est ce que voudriez faire aussi ça fait
quand même temps je n'ai pas travaillé
plus de sept ans j'ai changé de crédit
philippe 47 ans s'est porté volontaire
pour l'expérimentation installé dans la
nièvre avec femme et enfants l'emploi
qu'on lui avait promis n'a pas abouti
c'est le début de la galère depuis il
enchaîne les petits boulots mais le
travail se fait de plus en plus rares
tout m'est permis moto vl pl brevet
d'étude de paix de mécanique automobile
hilton formation sécurité là c'est mon
certificat pour tous qui couverture
cette vente a fait plein de choses
si tu devais dire ce que tu fais mieux
ça la sécurité c'est le jeu plus de
diplômes au delà des noms déjà deux ans
qu'il n'a pas exercé d'activité et ils
ne voient pas le bout du tunnel
qu'est-ce qui est le plus difficile
quand on est au chômage de longue durée
un milieu le regard des enfants puisque
la valeur dire travailler lieu à l'école
qui la réponse est là pour faire comme
eux à être au chômage et l'annoncé pas
paraître encore merci on a une
rhétorique en témoigne mois avant tout
chez cheval s'il y travailler trois
pages peut alors répond sa période de
noël de faire des cadeaux
concernant le palais en chiens de
faïence c'est parce que ça parmi les
chômeurs de longue durée il y a aussi
des archis diplômés comme cet ancien
chef d'entreprise dans le secteur du
tourisme philippe gagné 5000 euros par
mois en moyenne
qu'est-ce qu'on essaie désormais au rsa
il a envoyé entre 100 et 120 cv en vain
vous avez été gérant du directeur
général la d'entreprise de tourisme a
priori mais on vous a révélé les
structures et quand on voit le cursus
les gens la première chose qu'ils ont
alors ouvrez le pdg qui se dit ça peut
être intéressant mais ce monsieur là il
ya 57 ans donc même si mettre quelque
chose en place tiendra en effet
longtemps donc voilà on va pas
capitalisé effectivement eu ce qu'il en
est et puis les gens qui nous reçoivent
qui sont parfois
mais la peur cet ancien patron
le projet zéro chômeur de longue durée
c'est l'espoir d'un nouveau départ
sojana peut justement pousser les gens à
sortir un peu de cette galère depuis
déjà savoir qu'on existe qu'on est là et
qu'on peut faire quelque chose mais il
se trouve que ça c'est la démarche n'est
pas moi qui m'a le plus plu dans ce
projet par des deux
en tant qu'ancien chef d'entreprise
philippe n'a pas droit au chômage
il a quitté la région parisienne pour
raisons familiales mais ces projets
n'ont pas fonctionné lorsque moi jean
vauchère des gens je me disais toujours
ces gens là cherchent un job un jour ça
pour avec moi je pensais pas que ça
m'arriverait et ben voilà c'est pour ça
que je vous dise ça peut arriver à tout
le monde parce que je suis confronté
aujourd'hui à ça à 57 ans je pensais pas
que ça pouvait être possible
je me rends compte qu'on est dans une
conjoncture aujourd'hui sa frappe tout
le monde à n'importe quel âge est
désormais philippe se sentent abandonnés
par pôle emploi on n'intéresse plus les
gens de pôle emploi ont leur coûte rien
donc quelque part ça les dérange pas du
tout de ne pas vous contacter de ne rien
vous proposer en plus de ça on m'a bien
fait comprendre que je suis dans un
cadre où et en seniors c'est extrêmement
difficile de nous pouvoir nous proposer
des postes et donc dernièrement c'est
moi qui les airs contacté à plusieurs
reprises par mail pour essayer d'avoir
des entretiens
on revient vers nous en nous disant
qu'on effectivement on est toujours dans
les cadres de pôle emploi qu'on est bien
considéré en tant que chercheur d'emploi
mais que à ce jour il ya toujours rien à
nous proposer
un sentiment d'abandon partagé par david
sans activité depuis trois ans ce matin
il se rend à pôle emploi
j'ai 47 ans ce soit online pu ou
pourront points vont jamais trop intérêt
je me suis toujours dit je viens je
m'inscris je fais ce que je dois faire
mais je me suis toujours dès mardi par
madame meyer moment qu'il ya bien le
chômage ils essayent il peut prendre une
plus elle essaya peut pas nous on essaye
en art et foi pour participer à
l'expérimentation il faut être inscrit
au chômage depuis plus d'un an
mais comme de nombreux chômeurs de
longue durée david a été radié faute de
s'être réactualisé dans la nièvre
le chômage a continué sa progression en
2015 +3 8% et pas d'éclaircie en
perspective face à ce constat pôle
emploi accueille ce dispositif d'un bon
oeil
nous nous refusons service public de
l'emploi considéré que des personnes
sont sur le bord de la route de manière
définitive la problématique et l'accès à
l'emploi de ces publics par un emploi de
proximité disponible qui n'existe pas
aujourd'hui donc l'intérêt de
l'expérimentation séquelles recréer des
emplois de proximité qui sont en
cohérence avec la mobilité et les
qualifications de ses publics
l'objectif est de créer des activités
non rentables mais socialement utiles à
partir de besoins nouveaux notamment
dans le secteur de l'environnement et
pour le prouver
la sénatrice anne emery dumas nous amène
sur les berges de la nièvre
alors qu'est ce que vous prévoyez de
faire là donc s'il ya que les branches
sont que les branches basses
oui surtout de ce côté là et puis de
l'autre côté on voit qu'on a des arbres
morts également
voilà c'est principalement des travaux
du canal et tout ça c'est dans le cadre
du contrat de rivière d'accord eh bien
je me sens plus l'entretenir pour
différentes raisons
les propriétaires ne font plus
l'entretien parce qu'il soit ne savent
pas forcément qu'ils ont le
le devoir de les faire soi comme on est
en milieu rural sont principalement des
agriculteurs ils n'ont pas forcément le
temps qu'il faut pour pouvoir entretenir
comme il faut et berges on quand une
faune ils font pas forcément que les
bonnes techniques
autre possibilité de création d'emplois
réhabiliter les jardins ouvriers
aujourd'hui à l'abandon pour cultiver un
potager
le but ici répondre aux besoins du
territoire en circuit court pour
alimenter le collège la maison de
retraite et proposer à la population des
paniers de fruits et de légumes
mais quand même un peu au-delà du jardin
quand on voit la superficie est passée
dessus toute une symbolique aussi à
reprendre à reprendre l'exploitation
maraîchère de ceux de ses terrains
puisque c'est en fausses et c'est un peu
aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait une fois cuisine
n'est plus là quoi et comment on peut
arriver à recréer de l'emploi
quand on a perdu l'emploi industriel
avec peu de peu de possibilité de
recréer de l'emploi industriel pure sur
un territoire comme celui-là tube ce qui
est des choses comment recréer de
l'emploi dans des régions sinistrées
c'est tout l'enjeu du projet territoire
0 chômeurs de longue durée
ancien cadre de l'industrie
métallurgique
cet homme est à l'origine de la loi pour
patrick valentin responsable du réseau
emploi formation à atd quart monde il
faut se débarrasser de nos schémas de
compréhension classique on change
complètement la le paradigme la manière
de concevoir l'emploi c'est ça qu'il
faut bien avoir à l'esprit c'est pas que
ce soit des services à la personne du de
l'entretien ménager ou de l'entretien du
bâtiment ou de l'agriculture ou ou quel
que soit le type d'emploi ce qui fait la
différence c'est que l'emploi n'est plus
un simple outil de fabrication pour une
industrie ou un commerce à but lucratif
l'emploi est un produit de première
nécessité sociale et sept emplois nous
allons le produire ensemble
pour financer ces emplois en cdi la loi
crée un fonds d'expérimentation
territoriales contre le chômage de
longue durée
ce fonds permettra de créer des
entreprises conventionnés elle
embaucheront les chômeurs de longue
durée en cdi avec les allocations qu'ils
ne toucheront plus pour amorcer la pompe
l'état va abonder ce fonds à hauteur de
10 millions d'euros environ
pipriac ton ille et vilaine sur ce
territoire de 4000 habitants entre
rennes et redon on compte 150 chômeurs
de longue durée
déjà un an et demi que les acteurs
locaux se sont emparés du projet denis
prost est le responsable d'at et
d'écarts monde une fois par mois
chômeur élus et entrepreneurs se
réunissent au sein du comité de pilotage
local est au coeur des discussions
les modalités de mise en place du projet
lui faisait du projet des cours du tour
f
la prestation le but de l'entreprise
cnet le maximum de personnes à l'emploi
donc je vais pouvoir créer le maximum de
personnes au maximum d'emplois possible
on va essayer de faire la prestation
dans moins cher possible tout en
respectant les clips de l'entreprise
donc à partir de là le taux horaire qui
sera qui sera fixé ça sera le tour le
minimum qu'on pourra vous faire parce
qu'après je sais bien qu'il ya un niveau
d'eau que ça marche ce rapport en branle
un intérimaire qui sera qualifie direct
métier autant le je pense que le point
de bascule y sera pas ce sera pas trop
une maîtrise qu'on aura pour les chefs
d'entreprises implantées sur le
territoire la création d'une nouvelle
entité qui offrirait de la main d'oeuvre
à bas coûts pourrait créer une
concurrence déloyale
la question principale que ce soit de la
part des élus où que ce soit de la part
des entreprises c'était la question de
la concurrence
est ce que cette entreprise est là pas
venir finalement de prendre notre
travail faire du travail low cost et
puis et puis du coup casser le marché
donc nous on a vraiment expliqué il a
fallu prendre pas mal de temps pour bien
expliquer la démarche dire qu'on n'avait
aucun intérêt à faire ça parce que nous
notre indicateur de réussite ce sera la
baisse du chômage et que si on fait
travailler des gens en détruisant n'ont
pas d'autres personnes le chômage y
bougera pas donc c'est pas assez pas
l'objectif
l'objectif est bien de créer des
activités nouvelles d'utilité publique
sans empiéter sur les emplois existants
si tu as un service très très
particuliers qui rapporte rien mais qui
le territoire qui combine aussi à une
meute on allait visiter des personnes
isolées
la prod derrière de facturation qui va
être énorme mais par contre ça fait
partie d'un projet d'ensemble qui fait
que à la fois ci du travail aussi bien
temps de travail mais qui compensait par
d'autres acquittés qui elles sont plus
rémunératrices parce que elles sont
proches du secteur concurrentiel sans le
gênait parce que c'est pas occuper c'est
validé par le comité local
c'est une activité comprendra pas que
par des réseaux mais qui peut quand même
être facturé années tend à 18 euros de
l'heure qui fait que ça compense aussi
d'autres aux activités moins
rémunératrice vous avez d'un côté
l'emploi vendredi rentable dans le
secteur privé à mettons voilà
entreprises classiques qui font cette 7e
voilà ça ça existe c'est en place
aujourd'hui c'est pas parfait mais
ensuite ça existe de l'autre côté on a
aussi l'emploi du public dès que par les
collectivités qui elle effectivement
bien rempli ce plein de mission et je
crois qu'on est entre les deux on à
l'emploi semi solvables celui qui est
peut-être pas encore complètement
rentable parce qu'on l'a pas
expérimentée parce qu'on n'a pas essayé
et l'autre celui qui ne sera jamais
parce que mais qui peut quand même
généré quelques recettes mais la
frontière entre l'emploi rentable et
l'emploi non rentables et parfois mince
emmanuel patty est directeur de
l'association locale de services à la
personne
donc là on va essayer madame pinault
pour une intervention
des de broome particulièrement pour le
ménage on va aller voir madame pinault
et nathalie gal auxiliaires de vie aides
aux devoirs ménages préparation de repas
pour les personnes âgées
il emploie une soixantaine de personnes
sur le territoire dans le cadre du
projet il compte proposer de nouveaux
services à la population dans
interventions elles sont souvent très
courte une demi heure trois quart
d'heure 2 heures maximum
alors là l'action pourrait nous
permettre de mettre en place des
interventions beaucoup plus longue d'une
demi-journée éventuellement même d'une
journée entière
le couper du bois chez une personne
accompagné une autre une autre personne
pour une sortie mis bout à bout ça fait
des activités qui peuvent qui peuvent
être créatrice d'emplois pour les
entreprises locales le dispositif est
une aubaine elle espère pouvoir
embaucher des chômeurs de longue durée à
moindre coût sur des missions
ponctuelles
jean michel côté est artisan maçon
réticents à l'origine il est désormais
partie prenante du comité de pilotage
j'ai changé mon regard sur les chômeurs
j'avais une fausse idée que baup et ils
se complaisent dans leur situation alors
que pour certaines personnes le chômage
et le vivent comme un calvaire
et si on peut leur aider à sentir mieux
et retrouver un travail bien tant mieux
après s'ils retravaillent après bannour
dynamise note notre région
localement bien sûr et bayer après c'est
des gens qui peuvent leur permettre de
consommer qui peuvent à faire des
travaux on voit nos intérêts nous aussi
si les gens consomment en faire des
travaux on pérennise notre entreprise
cet artisan compte ainsi embaucher des
chômeurs de longue durée dans le cadre
du projet pour alléger son temps de
travail
ce week-end je fais l'entretien du
matériel du véhicule du dépôt de tout et
là ça me permettra de peut-être
quelqu'un un moindre coût pour le coup
mais
et sans que les boîtes d'intérim le
propose sans que personne ne propose
quoi
comme ce chef d'entreprise philippe est
investi dans le projet à pipriac
à 59 ans il a connu trois licenciements
consécutifs
ancien chauffeur ambulancier il lui
manque huit trimestres avant de pouvoir
prétendre à la retraite
pour lui le projet zéro chômeur de
longue durée c'est une façon de terminer
convenablement son parcours
professionnel jour arrive arrive la
solution peut-être miracle voilà qui
s'appelle territoire et aux chômeurs qui
s'appelle atd quart monde épie qui vient
qui via nous nous propose est peut-être
quelque chose de complètement hors du
temps je voudrais bien chez lire
correctement ma carrière professionnelle
quoi voilà et de gagner 1200 1300 euros
par mois ou même que 1100 euros avec
territoire zéro chômeur à partir de la
fin de l'année ce sera toujours mieux
que d'en avoir 700 à pôle emploi et puis
de se ronger son frein tous les jours à
la maison
pour philippe comme pour mireille 41 ans
le projet est un ballon d'oxygène au
chômage depuis deux ans elle a deux
enfants et son mari est également sans
emploi grâce au projet elle se sent
enfin utile
en tout cas je peux pas des pâtes que
des chips jeu lui qui s'y met lui aussi
tient à l'ego la première séance a été
génial à part ton de tout de suite je
parce que j'ai trouvé une superbe idée
ce que je vaux bon tant qu'habitant de
pipriac
je voyais bien qu'il ya des choses à
faire pourquoi pourquoi il faut pas il
ya six à faire et pourquoi ça y'a plus
comme les transports que quand je suis
arrivé à pipriac au départ avec trans un
coeur qui nous alerte dans les journaux
il ya plus de cars donc pourquoi ils ont
enlevé vont financièrement je suppose
mais il n'y a plus d'autres forcément
les gens qui n'ont pas les moyens de
transport ou moins bon deux jets petites
voitures j'ai eu un rendez vous je ne
peux pas pu y aller pour beaucoup de
chômeurs vivent sur des petits
territoires isolés
la question de la mobilité est un frein
supplémentaire
une des activités créatrices d'emplois
pourraient être une ligne de transport
entre redon et pipriac chez les chômeurs
de longue durée le dispositif créé un
espoir immense mais au plan national on
est plus sceptique
maurad rabhi a étudié le dispositif à la
loupe pour la cgt je ne veux pas qu'on
crée de faux espoirs vis-à-vis des
personnes qui sont en attente
justement parce que on n'a pas le droit
on doit être responsable jusqu'au bout
et de responsables jusqu'au bout c'est à
dire qu'on n'a pas inventé un dispositif
miracle bertrand martinot et économiste
pour lui aussi ce projet est une réponse
insuffisante au chômage comme on a un
chômage de masse il faut aussi passer
par ce traitement social du chômage mais
le vrai problème de l'économie française
c'est pas de créer davantage d'emplois
publics pour lesquels on est déjà les
champions du monde
la question c'est que les emplois dans
ce secteur concurrentiel dans le secteur
marchand ne sont pas créés en france
avec les entreprises ne crée pas
d'emplois je rappelle que depuis quinze
ans on n'a pas créé un emploi nettes
dans le secteur marchand on a créé que
des emplois publics et malheureusement
beaucoup de chômeurs
ce dispositif suscite encore de
nombreuses questions quid de la
formation des chômeurs de la concurrence
déloyale ou encore de la mise à
disposition de main d'oeuvre à bas coût
à des entreprises du secteur marchand
autant de questions qui restent en
suspens mais le projet a déjà permis une
chose changer le regard sur la valeur
travail
si l'emploi est un produit de première
nécessité sociale pour la cohésion d'une
société alors s'il est utopique de
vouloir que l'emploi soit un droit oui
nous sommes utopique
allez-y toujours en mai l'opra alesi pas
pour les postes mettez les au niveau du
torse là en attendant de retrouver une
activité
philippe s'investit en donnant des cours
de karaté aux jeunes en situation de
handicap sur le tatami il déverse la
colère qui est en lui
ça permet un peu de ce extérioriser un
peu toute cette rage qu'on a dans la
situation dans laquelle je suis et
quelque part à maaf autant la mettre à
bonne escient en faire profiter les
autres quoi pour moi déjà c'est le fait
d'être dans la vie active
le pouvoir donné de ma personne de faire
participer mon expérience bénéficie mon
expérience pardon à d'autres et puis
surtout ne pas être coupé non plus de la
société parce que quelque part c'est
extrêmement important
le projet territoire des roux chômeurs
de longue durée est ambitieux mais il
reste modeste dans son expérimentation
un bilan est prévu au bout de cinq ans
avant une éventuelle généralisation
prochaine étape en septembre avec la
mise en place des entreprises à but
d'emplois dans les territoires pilotes
parmi les lois d'expérimentation
couronnée de succès il ya le rsa un pari
réussi